اعتقال المشتبها فيه بتسريب الوثائق
والبنتاجون يامروا بمراجعه شامله لاليات
الوصول للمعلومات السريه
عدن تستقبل تستعد لاستقبال الدفعه الاولى
من الاسرى المحررين من سجون الحوثيين
والتي تشمل 72 اسيرا
البرهان يتوافقان بعد اجتماعين منفصلين مع
الرباعي على تشكيل اليه عسكريه مشتركه
لخفض التصعيد
[موسيقى]
طبت اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى هذه النشره
الاخباريه من العربيه اعتقل عملاء مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي شخصا يشتبه به في
تسريب وثائق البنتاجون السريه ونشرت وسائل
اعلامنا امريكيه لحظه اعتقال المشتبه به
في مدينه دايتون بولايه ماسا شوسس الذي
اشار التقرير
لنيويورك تايمز الى انه يدعى جاك
وزير العدل الامريكي
قال ان المشتبه به بتسريب وثائق البنتاجون
يعمل في سلاح الجو التابع للحرس الوطني
الامريكي
اليوم قامت وزاره العدل باعتقال جاك
دوجلوستشيره في اطار تحقيق حول تسريب
وثائق تحتوي على معلومات سريه عن قطاع
الدفاع الوطني تشير موظف لدى سلاح الجو
التابع للحرس الوطني عملاء مكتب التحقيق
الفيدرالي القوا القبض على توشيره هذه
الظهيره مبدئيا سوف يعرض على محكمه مقاطعه
ماساشوست
من جهته اعلن البنتاجون ان التحقيقات لا
تزال مستمره بشان مسرب الوثائق السريه
وايضا حول ما اثير عبر وسائل الاعلام عن
محتوى تلك الوثائق
مثلماكون ياخذ موضوع تسريبات الوثائق على
محمل الجد وصلنا العمل الاستخباراتي على
مدار الساعه لكشف ملابسات الامر وكيفيه
سير التحقيق بشان المسرب الوثائق السريه
وماذا سنتحدث عن الوثائق المسربه الحساسه
على خاصه ما اثير عبر وسائل الاعلام عن
محتوى تلك الوثائق
[موسيقى]
وافادت شبكه سي ان ان المعتقل في موضوع
الوثائق السريه لديه اراء غير تقليديه
فيما يخص سياسه امريكا اشارت الى انه وضع
قيودا على السلاح وكان يحاول لفت انتباه
المنتسبين الى التطبيق الذي نشر عليه
الوثائق السريه من جانبها قالت صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز ان المعتقل قد يواجه تهما
تصل الى عشر سنوات عن كل جرم مشيره الى
انه سيواجهه تهم الحاق الضرر في الولايات
المتحده
كيف بدات قصه نشر التسريبات العسكريه
الامريكيه ومن اين ومن هو جاك تشيره الذي
ورط نفسه في نشر الوثائق السريه نتابع كل
ذلك
هنا بدات القصه موقع ديسكورد
لقاء افتراضي لحوالي 30 فردا دردشه
اعتياديه لا غير شباب ومراهقين دقائق حتى
تحول الحديث دون قصد لتبادل الاهتمامات في
مناقشه الحرب في اوكرانيا وهنا وقع
المحظور
شاب عشريني يدير مجموعه دردشه يعمل منذ
عام في الحرس الوطني الجوي الامريكي نشرت
تلقائيا عشرات الوثائق العسكريه
جاك توشيبا احرج امريكا واربك العالم بلا
قسط
الشرطه الامريكيه لم يغمض لها جفن
قبضت على توشيره للتحقيق في تسريبات وصل
صداها العالم غذاء السالم العربيه
[موسيقى]
هكذا وزير الدفاع الامريكي في بيان له ان
وزاره الدفاع ستواصل في شراكه وثيقه مع
مجتمع الاستخبارات والشركاء الاخرين
مراجعه الاثار المترتبه على الامن القومي
نتيجه تسريب الوثائق غير المصرح به واضاف
لن نتردد في اتخاذ اي اجراءات اضافيه
ضروريه للحفاظ على اسرار امتنا وبناء على
ذلك او عزاء الى وكيل وزاره الدفاع
للاستخبارات والامن لاجراء مراجعه لمن
تصلهم المعلومات الاستخباراتيه واجراءات
المسائله والرقابه داخل الوزاره منعا
لتكرار هذا النوع من التسريبات
تستعد عدم نقل لاستقبال الدفعه الاولى من
الاسرى المحررين من سجون الحوثيين والتي
تشمل اثنين او 70 اسيرا بينهم وزير الدفاع
الاسبق اللواء الركن محمود الصبيحي وشقيق
الرئيس السابق اللواء الركن ناصر منصور
هادي وكانت الحكومه اليمنيه اعلنت تاجيل
بدء عمليات تبادل الاسرى والمعتقلين مع
الحوثيين الى الجمعه بدلا من يوم الخميس
وفي مارب جرى تبادل جثامين اسرى بين
المقاومات الشعبيه وجماعه الحوثي عبر وسيط
محلي بين مارب والجوف وقال هذه جمعان
الوسيط المحلي انه تم تبادل اربع جثث بين
اطراف النزاع في جبهه مارب واشار جمعان
الى ان اسماء الجثث المفرج عنها تم
تبادلها في الحدود الجغرافيه بين محافظتي
مارب والجوف
خلال اجتماعين منفصلين مع الاليه الرباعيه
اتفق البرهان ودجلو على تشكيل اليه عسكريه
مشتركه لبحث اجراءات خفض التصعيد خاصه في
مدينتي مدني ومروي على ان يعقد لقاء بين
الرجلين في ضوء نتائج الاليه وقد عبر
مبعوث اتروكا والاتحاد الاوروبي الى
السودان عن قلقهم من خطر التصعيد بين
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع
تسيطر حال من الترقب على المشهد الامني
والسياسي في السودان غدا تحركات لقوات
الدعم السريع نحو قاعده مروي العسكريه
شمال السودان تمت دون تنسيق مع الجيش
السوداني الموقف وما تلاه من تداعيات
وبيانات من الجيش والدعم السريع دفعت قوى
سياسيه وفاعلين دوليين للاسهام في خفض حده
التوتر ونزعفتي للازمه بين الجيش والدعم
السريع
وجب علينا ان ندقنا قوس الخطر يدق الجيش
السوداني ناقوس الخطر فثمت ما يدعو لاتخاذ
خطوات حاسمه
نحو الشمال السودان تتحرك قوات تابعه
للدعم السريع دون تنسيق مع القوات المسلحه
بحسب بيان الجيش تحركات وضعت المشهد
الامنيه امام اختبار ضبط النفس وطرح
التساؤلا حول مغزى تحركات قوات الدعم
السريع في هذا التوقيت بعد فشل المفاوضات
بين الجانبين في مساله الدمج اعتقد ان
الدعم السريع حاول انه يتحصل على مواقف
قويه بنشر قوات وافتعال ازمه لاداره
الازمه الاصليه
يتازم الموقف اذا تسارع قوى سياسيه على
راسها حزب الامه القومي لعقد لقاء يضم
كتلا سياسيه لبحث تداعيات الازمه تعلن
القوى السياسيه عن رايها صراحه ازاء ما
يحدث موقفنا بان هذا التحشيد وهذه هذا
التوتر يجب ان يوقف ويجب ان يعالج بصوره
عاجله جدا ويجب ان تجلس قياده الطرفين
للوصول الى تفاهمات حول نقاط المختلف
حولها
على خط الازمه ايضا تدخل الحركات الموقعه
على اتفاق سلام جوبا كما تزعل رباعيه
الدوليه لنزع فتيل التوتر وافساح المجال
لانجاح الاتفاق الايطالي فالازمه بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع وضعت العمليه
السياسيه امام خيارات محدده
اما ان تتوقف وتتجمد العمليه السياسيه في
حال تطورت الاحداث الى عنف او ان يتم
تطوير الاتفاق الايطالي ليستوعب اراء وقوه
اخرى خارج الاتفاق الايطالي واعتقد ان
المؤشرات نحو الثاني هي الابرز
الخلافات الراهنه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع اخذت منحا تصاعديا خلال الساعات
الماضيه فتاثيرات الازمه وصلت الى طور
الانتقال من المربع الامني لتنعكس على
عموم المشهد السياسي في البلاد نزار
البغداوي العربيه الخرطوم
قال قائد القوات افاقنار الروسيه
انه من السابق لاوانه الحديث عن سيطره
كامله لمدينه باخ موت شرقيه اوكرانيا تزمن
هذا مع تاكيد وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قوات فاغنرت تواصلوا دفع القوات
الاوكرانيه الى خارج وسط بخموت واشارت
الدفاع الروسيه في بيانها اليومي الى ان
طائرات قوات الدعم او القوات الروسيه دعمت
فاجنر باثني عشره طلعه جويه في باخموت
ونفذت 57 عمليه عمليه قصف صاروخي ومدفعي
من جهته اعلن المتحدث باسم الدفاع الروسيه
تنفيذ قوات عمليات قتاليه مكثفه لطرد
القوات الاوكرانيه من مدينه بخموت نظريه
في اتجاه دونيتسك واصلت قوه فاجنر
الهجوميه عمليه قتاليه عاليه الكثافه لطرد
العدو من الاحياء المركزيه لمدينه ارتيموس
فيما تقدم القوات المحموله جوا الدعم
لتقدم القوات المهاجمه وعرقله نقل
احتياطات الجيش الاوكراني الى المدينه
وامكانيه انسحاب وحدات العدو من هناك
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه في بيانها
انها لن تمدد اتفاق تصدير الحبوب عبر
البحر الاسود التي توسطت فيه الامم
المتحده الا اذا ذلل الغرب سلسله من
العقبات امام تصدير الحبوب والاسمده
الروسيه مؤكده انها لن تكون هناك حاجه الى
الحديث عن تمديد تمديد اخر لمبادره البحر
الاسود الا اذا كان هناك تقدم في حل
المشكلات النهجيه
اعترضت انظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسيه طائره
النرويجيه من طرازيه بثمانيه بوسيدون فوق
بحر بارنيتس وكانت تحاول الاقتراب من
الحدود الروسيه وذلك وفق مركز مراقبه
الدفاع الوطني الروسي واوضح المركز ان
مقاتله الروسيه من طراز ميج 31 رافقت
الهدف لمنع انتهاكه للحدود الروسيه وبين
انه اتابع لسلاح الجو النرويجيه
صوت مجلس شيوخ بعد مجلس النواب في
البرلمان الروسي يوم الاربعاء على قانون
اثار قانون اثار خوف الاشخاص الذين لا
يريدون القتال في اوكرانيا كونه يسهل
التعبئه في الجيش ويعاقب [__] استلام
استدعائهم
تلقي امر التعبئه لتجنيد الاجباري في
روسيا اصبح الان الكترونيا بعد ان كان
يسلم باليد هذا التشريع جديد الذي اقره
مجلس النواب الروسي يسهل عمليه استدعاء
المجندين للمشاركه في العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا
دون وجود اي صوت معارض وصوت واحد امتنع عن
التصويت خيارات التهرب من الاستدعاء
العسكري امام المواطنين الروس اصبحت قليله
الان
تجاهلوا الاستدعاء او تغيير مكان السكن او
حتى مغادره البلاد لم تعد ممكنه الان لان
الاستدعاء سيصل الى تطبيق الالكتروني
للخدمات الحكوميه الروسيه في الهاتف
المحمولاس روسيا دوله كبيره وتعداد السكان
فيها كبير وهذه عوامل هامه لاطلاق مثل هذا
النظام الرقمي لارسال الاستدعاء الكترونيا
سياخ
كان يجب سن هذا القانون منذ زمن طويل
لتفادي الفوضى التي حصلت
سمعت بهذا القانون ولا اريد التعليق عليه
ضروره لكن الدوله التي يحكمها الامن دوله
ضعيفه
تبريرات الكريم للاجراء الذي اقره النواب
بانه تعديل تقني ضروري من اجل تحسين
وتحديث نظام التعبئه الوطنيه لم تنهي
مخاوف المواطنين الروس من اعلان جديد
للتعبئه في البلاد كانت طعمي العربيه
موسكو
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
الامير محمد بن سلمان يطلق اربعه مناطق
اقتصاديه خاصه امام المستثمرين من كل
انحاء العالم
حياكم الله
اكدت نقابات الفرنسيه التي تقود
الاحتجاجات ضد قانون التقاعد الجديده ان
اكثر من مليون متظاهر خرجوا امس للاحتجاج
على قانون التقاعد وافاد مراسل العربيه
بتعرض 22 من عناصر الشرطه في باريس واليوم
للاصابه خلال مواجهات في الاحتجاجات
[تصفيق]
المجلس الدستوري يستعد يوم اليوم الجمعه
للفصل في مدى شرعيه قانون التقاعد المثير
للجدل وقد اعلن المتحدث باسم الحكومه
الفرنسيه اوليفر فيران حضره التجمعات في
محيطيه مبنى المجلس الدستوري
قررت رئيسه الوزراء بنفسها احاله المساله
الى المجلس الدستوري وهو سلطه مستقله
ستخبرنا ما اذا كان مشروع القانون متوافقا
مع الدستور وهكذا نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
المسار الديمقراطي من الواضح اننا نبحث عن
التهدئه والحوار
[تصفيق]
اعلنا ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان اطلاقها اربع مناطق اقتصاديه خاصه
في كل من الرياض جازان راس الخير مدينه
الملك عبد الله الاقتصاديه في رابغ المدن
الاقتصاديه الخاصه الجديده ستقدم حوافز
للشركات بمعدلات ضرائب تنافسيه
واعفاءات الواردات ومدخلات الانتاج
والالات والمواد الخام من الرسوم الجمركيه
والسماح بالملكيه الاجنبيه بنسبه مئه
بالمئه والقدره على استقطابيه افضل
الموارد البشريه العالميه وتمثل المناطق
الاقتصاديه الجديده مرحله اولى من برنامج
سعودي طويل المدى يستهدف جذب شركات
الدوليه وتشجيع الاستثمار الاجنبي المباشر
وتعزيز نمو القطاعات النوعيه المستقبليه
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
اكد ان المناطق الاقتصاديه الخاصه ستفتح
افاقا جديده للتنميه معتمده على المزايا
التنافسيه لكل لكل منطقه لدعم القطاعات
الحيويه والوعده ومنها اللوجستيه
والصناعيه والتقنيه وغيرها واوضح ولي
العهد السعودي ان المناطق الاقتصاديه
الخاصه تتمتع بنظم تشريعيه ولوائح خاصه
للنشاطات الاقتصاديه ستجعلها من الاكثر
تنافسيه في العالم واشار الامير محمد بن
سلمان الى ان المناطق الاقتصاديه تتيح
فرصا هائله لتنميه الاقتصاد المحلي
واستحداث الوظائف ونقل التقنيه وتوطين
الصناعات واضاف ولي العهد الى ان المناطق
الاقتصاديه الخاصه تشكل منصات اللوجستيه
وصناعيه متكامله ترسخ مكانه المملكه
كبوابه عبور لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا
وحلقه وصل بين اسواق الشرق والغرب
في العراق اعلنها زعيم التيار الصدري
العراقي مقتدى الصدر تجميد التيار الصدري
لمده عام باستثناء صلاه الجمعه وهيئه
التراث مشيرا الى فداحه استمراره في قياده
التيار وفيه بعض الفاسدين كما اعلن زعيم
التيار الصدري تجميد حسابه على منصه تويتر
وذلك في تغريده فادت بان الحساب مغلق حتى
اشعار اخر ويرى مراقبون ان قرار صدر
تجميده عمل التيار لمده عام قد يشمل عدم
المشاركه في الانتخابات المحليه التي من
المقرر ان تجرى نهايه هذا العام
اكدت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه عن انالينا
ضروره توثيق العلاقات مع الصين مشدده على
ان بكين من اهم شركاء التجاريين
الواضح اننا لن نتمكن من تجاوز هذه القوه
العالميه دوله تضم مليارات البشر ومن اكبر
شركاءنا التجاريين ولكننا بحاجه الى تبادل
الوثيق لا سيما لصالح شعبنا واقتصادنا
تدريبات مدنيه تحاكي التاهب للكوارث
والحروب شاركه فيها اكثر من الف متطوع
تاتي التدريبات بعد المناورات العسكريه
الاخيره التي اجرتها الصين
وتضمنتها تدريبات سيناريوهات لهجمات
صاروخيه وهميه وانفجار بالاسلحه الكيماويه
والهجوم على محطه مترو
[موسيقى]
استطلعت العربيه اراء الشارع السوري عقب
زياره وزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل المقدادي
الى السعوديه والاتفاق على استئناف
الخدمات القنصليه بين البلدين
اكيد الشيء بيفيدنا نحن كمواطنين سوريين
اكيد فينا عوده العلاقات اطول شارك بخير
انت بخير
فما بالك سعوديه يعني عوده هي اله حجم
بالنسبه للدول العربيه
السعوديه اذا بتعود انا بتصوري هي بتعود
بالخير على الشعبين السوري والسعودي يكون
السلام يا عم
مشان الشعوب ومشان الاطفال استقبلنا
هالخبر شغله حلوه والحمد لله ان شاء الله
قادره خير بيننا وبينهم وهن بالاول
وبالاخير انه هنن العرب متنا متل هون
ونحنا واياهم يعني ما في شي بيناتنا
والحمد لله بركي بيتحسن الوضع الاقتصادي
وبنصير والفضل من الله يعني وهذا اللي
بدنا اياه
في المسجد النبوي وبين جنبات الروضه تظهر
الاساطير الثمانيه التي تعود او يعود
تاريخها الى 14 قرنا والتي تحكي قصصا
تاريخيه لكل منها مرتبطه باحداث نبويه
شهيره التفاصيل برفقه الزميل سلطان السلمي
[موسيقى]
رغم ما يشهده المسجد النبوي من توسعات على
مر التاريخ الا ان اساطينه ثمانيه بقيت
شاهده حتى وقتنا الحالي ولكل منها قصه
تاريخيه بالمسجد وتسمى باعمده الاساطير اذ
كانت من جذوع النخل قديما واشتهرت منها
سته اساطير وهي تقع بين جنبات الروضه
الشريفه وارتبطت باحداث السيره النبويه
دعايه الاسطوانات كانت اعمده جذوع نخل ثم
في عهد عثمان بن عفان اصبحت من الحجاره
المنقوشه ومحشوه بالرصاص ثم بعد ذلك في
عهد الوليد وعمر بن عبد العزيز تغيرت
الوضع استعمل الرخام الى عهد الملك فهد
رحمه الله كان في هناك ترميمات ويعاد كل
فتره لعمليه الصيانه وبالنسبه ضرب البويات
بالنسبه للاسطوانه منذ اربعه عشر قردا لا
تزال اساطير المسجد النبوي تحمل التي سميت
بها في العهد النبوي وتتزين اليوم باللون
الذهبي واصط لوحه خضراء ومن اهم هذه
الاساطير التي ارتبط موضوعها بتاريخ وسيله
النبي الاسطوانه المخللقه والتوبه والمحرس
الاسطوانه واسطوانه المخللقه وهي خلف
المحراب الموجوده الان النبوي الشريف
وسميت بالمخلقه لانه كانوا تطيب بطيب
الخلوق وهو افضل انواع الطب في زمن عمر بن
عبد العزيز اسطوانه السرير كان يوضع له
سرير عليه الصلاه والسلام اذا اراد
الاعتكاف بالمسجد اسطوانه الحرس او
اسطوانه علي بن ابي طالب رضي الله عنه
اللي كانوا يحرس الرسول عليه الصلاه
والسلام
[موسيقى]
اسطوانه المفقوده كان يستقبل عند الوفود
اسطوانه
التوب اللي كان يربط وربط فيها ابو لبابه
نفسه ثم اسطوانه عائشه عنها ويقال اول
بدايه تحول القبله صلى عنده عليه الصلاه
والسلام لمده ثلاثه اشهر ثم تقدم محراب
النبوي الموجود في الروضه الحاليه تلقى
الاساطير القابعه بالروضه الشريفه عنايه
واهتماما كبيرا من قبل رئاسه شؤون الحرمين
اذ شهدت عمليات ترميم وتحسين مستمره من
المسجد النبوي سلطان السلمي العربيه
باب الخليل الذي يعد احد ابواب مدينه
القدس له عده اسماء منها بابيه فهو باب
الخليل
ويشتهر الباب بتواجد بسطات بيع كعك القدس
من امامه على مدار السنه يزوره السياح من
كل انحاء العالم للتجول في السوق القريبه
منه
اكبر ابواب القدس وتقول الروايات ان كل
عدو اراد ان يغزو القدس دخل من هذا الباب
لانه قرب الباب توجد قلعه وهذه القلعه
تسمى قلعه القدس اعتبرت المكان الذي تحكم
منه مدينه القدس ويقيم الحاكم فيها
قرب باب الخليل يوجد سوق البازار او سوق
باب الخليل كان في الماضي سوقا للخضار
ياتي القرويين من ضواحي القدس لبيع
بضائعهم فيه لكن تم تحويله الى محلات تبيع
تذكارات من التراث الفلسطيني للسياح
كعك القدس تكون دائما حاضره في المكان
ورائحتها تتجول مع التجار قريبا من الباب
ومن يزور باب الخليل سيتمكن من الذهاب في
مسار فوق اسوار القدس ويتمتع بجمال
المدينه لان كل غاصي من القدس العربيه
شهدت العاصمه الاردنيه عمان هطوله امطار
غزيره عدت الى ارتفاع منسوب المياه في عدد
من شوارع المدينه ونشر موقع طقس العرب
مقاطع مصوره لحاله طرق في عده احياء بعمان
واظهرت المقاطع غرق بعضها تشهد البلاد
منخفضا جويا من الدرجات الثالثه وفقا
للارصاد الجويه الاردنيه
متابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات